الى الولايات المتحده ملامح المنافسه داخل
الحزب الجمهوري على الانتخابات الرئاسيه
تتضح شيئا فشيئا الرئيس الجمهوري السابق
دونالد ترامب الذي كان معروفا ترشحه يجد
امامه لحد الان 11 منافسا راغبا في الفوز
بثقه الحزب الجمهوري وتبقى حظوظه بعض
هؤلاء المرشحين قائمه نوعا ما رغم ان كفه
ترامب هيل الارجح بلغه الاستطلاعات
12 مرشحا جمهوريا للانتخابات الرئاسيه
الامريكيه
فما هي ابرز هذه الاسماء
دونالد ترامب الرئيس الامريكي السابق صاحب
الحظوظ الاوفر حسب استطلاعات الراي
حكموا ولايه فلوريدا اكتسب شعبيه كبيره في
السنوات الاخيره مايك بانس النائب السابق
للرئيس ترامب لا يحظى بقاعده جمهوريه
واسعه
الحاكم السابق لولايه نيوجيرسي ابدى رغبه
واضحه في عرقله
ترشحود سيناتور عن ولايه كارولاينا يطمح
في ان يصبح اول رئيس جمهوري من اصل افريقي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات